der metzger und die mächtigen
fleischkönig clemens tönnies und die
politiker sie haben ihn gefeiert und
mancher hat geld von ihm genommen und
nun lassen viele der mächtigen turniers
fallen machen den selfmade milliardär
zum alleinigen sündenbock
ausgerechnet diejenigen die die
fleischindustrie kontrollieren sollten
bild hat nordrhein westfalens
gesundheitsminister karl josef laumann
konfrontiert turniers erst freund der
mächtigen dann ein sündenbock um vom
eigenen versagen abzulenken die politik
oder viele politiker bewusst das was
verläuft die wahrheit ist dass man die
eine mehrheit kräfte um die welt
vertreten zu verdienen war daraus immer
eine grundsätzliche frage gemacht worden
ist und was man natürlich auch sagen
muss dass es hier auch durchaus ein
zusammenspiel zwischen agra funktionären
strich der landwirtschaft und der
schlacht wirtschaft gegeben hat die
zusammen natürlich auch einfluss in der
politik haben und er ist im kreuzfeuer
der kritik sigmar gabriel ex spd chef ex
wirtschaftsminister und vizekanzler
er hatte einen lukrativen beratervertrag
bei turniers im bild interview erklärt
er sich nun anfang des jahres hat mich
natürlich gefragt ob ich ihm helfen
könnte weil drohen in
exportbeschränkungen nach asien weil
damals die afrikanische schweinepest
hier in europa im anmarsch
ich habe das dann im mai aus
persönlichen gründen beendet
dass er jetzt zum buhmann für die
gesamte kroner debatte gemacht hat das
gemisch wird das finde ich ehrlich
gesagt etwas überzogen
er ist jetzt das gesicht das man ab und
man sozusagen jenes im wahrsten sinn des
wortes jede schweinerei zu und doch die
eigenen parteigenossen kritisieren
gabriel bundesarbeitsminister hubertus
heil im bild interview bitten dieses
legitim ich sag's mal in den worten
meiner mutter es gibt situationen da
kommt mir das gefühl vor so etwas macht
man nicht
und das muss er selbst entscheiden ich
bedaure das aber das ist es dann auch